No loop.
I'm sorry.
I'm not a person right now.
Oh my god.
Give me a sec.
I'm not a person at the moment.
The 1230 time slot...
is truly the bane of my existence.
If we even ever start on time at 1230, like, a miracle just happened.
It's like when Jesus turned water into wine.
That is my miracle.
When I show up on time at 1230.
I do it for... I do it for the European dragoons out there.
This is the time slot for you.
Because you don't get much, especially for VTubers.
There's not a lot of opportunities to watch NA VTubers at a decent time.
So I do it for you, European dragoons.
The EU dragoons out there.
I do it for you.
Give me a sec, guys.
As always, it takes a little bit to rev up the Doki engine.
To start in the day.
So, like, you know how, like, cars in the morning... I know nothing about cars.
But you know how...
You know how cars in the morning, you know, they, like, stutter a bit.
And you gotta be like...
That's me right now.
That's me at the moment.
Also, like, I really wish I could do a lot of shit Dynasty Warriors.
But my throat is still recovering.
And all that shit.
So... and it's cold too.
So, like, it wasn't a great night for my throat.
I think the one thing I miss the most is just doing, like, long chatting streams after the game.
Which, obviously, I can't do.
Because...
Because I have to make sure I don't overdo my throat.
And overdo my voice.
So, like...
So, I'm trying my best to, like...
I'm trying my best to, like, pace myself when it comes to streaming.
And everything.
So, by the time... So, my voice will recover.
My voice will recover in time.
Oh my god!
This is for you, EU Kun!
Invictus, thank you for your very first...
I recognize an EU currency when I see one.
I recognize a European currency.
Where are you from?
That's right!
You're using Euros.
This is for you!
Hey, Doki.
First time superchatting.
Love your content.
Keep it up.
Use this wisely.
Oh my god.
Do you know how much a euro is in Canadian?
Euro to CAD.
That's one...
One euro is like 1.56 Canadian.
Oh my god.
I'm 50 cents richer, baby!
Thank you for your very first superchat.
I really...
I really appreciate it, guys.
Thank you so much.
Mac, thank you for your...
Oh my god, another euro!
EU, do you know how much 10 euro is?
I'm 5 dollars richer!
It's 15.56 Canadian!
Oh my god!
This is for you.
Mac, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
That's enough money to order fast food!
Actually, no.
That's actually a lot more money to order.
Like, actually not fast food.
You know like, how like...
I just realized...
I just realized like...
Oh my god!
Wait, is that a pound sign?
Wait, isn't pound more than euros now?
Let me check.
Pound to...
Yeah.
Oh my god!
85 cents more!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, that's 85 cents more.
Our Canadian dollar is so fucked, guys.
It's like...
Almost every currency in the world is like...
More expensive than Canadian dollars at the moment.
So we're like...
Financially, we're not...
Financially, for Canadians...
Our money is sort of like monopoly money at the moment.
And then people in...
People like in Zimbabwe is like...
Am I a joke to you right now?
And I'm like, look...
Look, we're considered a...
We're considered a first world country.
And like, things aren't looking great for us at the moment.
We're at...
We're at like...
We're at like a trade war right now.
So like, I'm a little worried.
Because like...
I don't know how long this trade war is gonna...
I don't know how long this trade war is gonna be, guys.
So I'm...
I'm a little worried right now.
Um...
Mac, thank you for the 5 gifted shits.
Thank you.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, so like...
I know I normally don't talk...
I don't talk about politics.
But I need to tell you guys this part.
Because it's so fucking funny.
Um...
Because like...
I got reached out...
By Canadian political party...
To like...
If I could be like a...
I could be like a...
Like a guest speaker...
For their party.
And then I was like...
When my manager told...
It was a...
I won't say which party.
But they were one of the big ones.
By the way.
They were one of the...
They were one of the big Canadian parties.
Because I recognized it.
I was like...
Oh my god.
What is this?
And then their email was like literally their political party.
And then so like...
My manager was like...
Oh my god.
So I was like...
Okay, we have something funny for you.
Like we have something like really interesting and funny.
And I was like...
Obviously I said no.
I don't want to be like...
I'm non-partisan.
So like...
Like as a content creator.
We have to...
You know.
Well, not have to.
But like...
I'm trying to be non-partisan for Canadian parties.
As a public figure.
As like a content creator.
I'm not trying to say like what.
But like...
For me I am.
But I was like...
Holy shit.
That's...
I was like...
Oh my god.
Cause you know.
I know why.
Because they're trying to get young voters.
So it's like...
It's like they're trying to get young voters to vote.
So if I like represent...
If I was like quote on quote their mascot or whatever.
They'll be like...
Guys remember to vote.
You know.
Cause it was supposed to be for like an election or some shit.
And I was just like...
What the fuck.
I was like...
That's crazy.
I was like what a fucking insane opportunity.
Like...
So it's like...
They're trying to get the VTuber voters guys.
They're trying to get...
They're trying to get the VTuber voters.
Cause we're the young...
We're the young voters.
Doki has the third party account.
I thought that was like...
I thought that was so funny.
Oh my gosh.
VTuber for parliament.
Wouldn't that be fucking insane?
V3, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Carl, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
AZ, thank you for the super chat.
My brother in Christ.
You set the time.
I'm European.
Thank you, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yes, and that's why it's at 12.30.
In the beginning of my...
In the beginning of my career.
When I first chose this time slot.
It wasn't even 12.30.
It was 12pm PST.
And then I was like...
I can't do it.
I don't even know...
I don't even know how long we lasted guys.
For the 12pm slot.
For the 12pm slot, we did not last very long.
And then after that, I was like...
I can't do it.
We needed those...
We needed those 30 minutes.
And then, even now, I'm like...
We gotta do...
We gotta be able to do this.
Because if we push it even more...
It's not even gonna be EU time anymore.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Maddie, thank you for the super chat.
I know what's wrong with her.
She ain't got no gamer subs in her.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
I was like...
I'm trying not to drink too much caffeine.
I've actually been like...
Trying my best to...
To like, wean myself off of caffeine.
Which I've been...
I actually haven't drank caffeine since...
The last time I drank gamer subs was for the tournament.
When I was like...
When I didn't sleep.
Because I was so nervous.
The VTuber Rivals tournament.
Because I was like...
Incredibly nervous.
And I couldn't sleep.
So I had like...
I think like two hours of sleep for that.
But then...
Before that...
I actually haven't drank like...
Any caffeine in a while.
Just because like...
I didn't want to be dependent on caffeine.
Like I...
At one point I was like...
A little bit too dependent on...
On...
On caffeine.
Because I was just tired all the time.
And I was like...
Oh, but if I drink caffeine...
I won't be tired.
But like...
I'm trying my best.
I am trying my best now.
I'm back to tea and...
I'm back to water.
Because tea also has caffeine.
But I'm back to water.
Anyway...
Today...
Might not...
I know usually I try to make a lot of streams with Dynasty Warriors.
But like...
My voice today is not the best.
And also...
I promised Gumi I'd show up for her collab.
Because she wanted me yesterday.
And I was like...
Oh...
I thought I was supposed to do a birthday thing with...
Oh, I should wish Elema a happy birthday real quick.
Guys...
I...
Give me a sec.
Also...
Happy...
Belated...
It's okay.
Also...
Happy...
Belated...
Your birthday.
I was gonna say it on stream.
But...
I forgot.
But here we go.
Okay.
I won't be streaming.
I also told her...
I won't be doing a long stream as well.
Like...
It'll be a...
I told her that like...
I won't be staying for too long.
Because, you know, obviously...
Obviously...
Like...
I...
I need a rest.
So...
I can't be...
I can't be doing long streams...
This week.
I wish I could.
I might try to go to a hospital tomorrow.
Because like...
Dude...
I should be able to trust the cleaners, right?
The cleaners aren't gonna take my stuff, right guys?
Tomorrow.
Because I have cleaners coming in tomorrow.
And...
And I'm wondering if like...
Do I need to supervise them?
Or like...
They won't take...
What are they gonna take?
Like...
All I have is like...
Is like...
Anime stuff.
Merch of me.
And I guess my PC.
The most expensive thing in my...
The most expensive thing in my apartment is literally my PC setup.
So like...
I guess if they have kids, they're like...
She won't notice this.
I guess I should stay.
But like...
I don't know.
I don't know if I should supervise.
Or anything.
They're like an actual company.
Yeah, they're a legit business.
So like...
What are they gonna do?
Take my GPU?
Like...
Oh my god.
If these...
If these cleaners...
Like...
Brought a set of screwdrivers.
Just so they can rob me of my GPU.
Like...
You know what?
They deserve it.
Like...
That is like the biggest con of my life.
But yeah.
I don't know.
I think it'll be fine.
Right?
They're like a legit company.
Okay.
I'll...
Oh, but then if I supervise them.
And then leave.
Then it'll be...
Okay.
I never trust strangers in my...
Yeah, but like...
If I talk to them.
And like...
Get to know them.
They won't be strangers then.
That's my loophole.
If I get to know them in five minutes.
They can't be strangers no more.
Okay.
Um...
Anyway.
Alright.
Simple minded.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You're gonna find out your doki bird and steal your clothes and sell them for money.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
That part.
I am a little concerned.
Because like...
I can't really hide my doki bird merch.
Because in my PC room.
It's like...
Okay.
I'm just gonna...
I'll take a picture of it.
Okay.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna like be buffering.
Because when I...
When I turn around.
Um...
I'm gonna be buffering.
When I turn around.
It's literally all doki birds.
Like this is me when I turn around.
And then this is all I see.
And it's just me.
Like it's...
It's literally...
It's literally just me.
So it's like...
Um...
There's really no hiding who I am.
Uh...
Because I have...
I actually have like a whole shrine.
Just...
Of me.
So...
Um...
That's gonna be a big problem in general.
Like...
Oh!
It's me and Sylveon.
By the way.
It's not...
There's a...
There's like a...
There's like a mini shrine of Sylveon.
Right there.
Like in the corner.
Like...
Like Sylveon has like a little special place.
In my shrine.
But it's me and Sylveon.
So...
I'm just like...
What do I do in that situation?
Like...
Like they may see like Sylveon.
And be like...
Oh, she likes Sylveon.
And then they're gonna see like...
Whoa, they really like this anime girl.
A lot.
And it's not...
And the shrine isn't even...
I have not finished the shrine by the way.
It is like a huge work.
It's been a work...
Because I think I'm moving...
I might be moving out.
Um...
I might be moving out this year.
So like...
I'm just like...
Oh man, I'm not gonna finish it.
So I never finished the shrine.
Just because I...
All I kept thinking about was like...
Maybe I have to...
I might have to move Nick this year.
So I never finished my shrine.
So it's just been...
Okay, so...
Alright, let me...
Um...
Okay, let me...
Let me send this over to myself.
So I can show it to you guys.
Okay, so...
This is what I'm most concerned about.
Um...
About...
Regarding like...
The cleaners coming over.
Um...
Because I can't pretend...
That like...
I mean, I could pretend I'm just a really, really big fan.
You know?
That's the only...
Wait, I just like...
I just really like this character.
And they'll just be like...
Oh my god, she's...
She...
She's a...
She's just...
A weeb.
You know?
That's like my only excuse.
I'm just a really, really big fan.
I'm just...
Incredibly obsessed with Doki Bird.
Yeah, I'll be like...
Oh my god, have you ever seen this VTuber called...
Have you ever watched this streamer?
I don't think they know what VTubers are.
I'll be like...
Have you ever watched this streamer called Doki Bird?
Oh my god.
You should really check her out.
Okay, here.
Let me show you guys.
Let me show you guys my...
Trying...
To myself.
That's it.
That's been incomplete for a couple of months now.
For like half...
I started this act a year ago and I never finished it.
Because I was like...
What if I move?
And then the only thing I added to it...
Like, I actually added to it...
Was like...
My Sylveon collection at the bottom.
Because I was like...
Where do I put this?
And I just put...
I just put it there.
Because I was like...
I don't know where to put this.
Okay, give me a sec.
Um...
Alright.
Here you go.
Like...
Guys.
Does this like...
Is...
Do you think...
Do you think it'll be weird?
Like...
I turn around...
And I...
Um...
I turn around...
And I just see this.
So like...
Do you think...
They'll think...
I'm Jokey Bird?
Or...
Um...
Or just like...
A really big...
No, that's not all of it.
I have stuff in storage.
This is literally the things I put out...
That I could put out.
Like...
Half a year ago, by the way.
I have majority of my stuff is like...
In storage right now.
And like...
It's like...
I just didn't have time to put stuff on it.
Do you think they'll just think I'm a...
I'm just a really big fan?
Just don't say...
Yeah, I just...
You just look...
Okay, good.
Okay, that's all I have.
I'm just a huge fan.
Plus, I love Sylveon.
Like...
The merch box.
I do.
Like, I have my drawers.
My drawers has like...
Um...
My drawers is like filled with like...
Uh...
Jokey Bird merch, basically.
They have to come into this room!
That's the thing!
Because, like...
That's where most of the fucking...
That's where a lot of cleaning has to be done.
Because this is my office.
Uh...
No!
Next scene.
I have a lot of merch.
But it's just all like...
Boxed up or like...
In my drawers.
Because I have not...
Done anything to this shrine since half a year ago.
Um...
Because I was like...
I might be moving.
So what's the point?
You know?
I was like...
I might be moving.
So...
What's the point guys?
Um...
They'll probably just think you're another eccentric rich...
Oh yeah, that makes me...
That does sort of make me...
Very eccentric.
They're like, yeah, we clean the...
I think they're gonna be like a couple of old ladies.
And they're just gonna be like...
Yeah, she has like...
A really big collection of like...
Of like...
Um...
This...
Blonde woman.
HAHAHAHA She's like...
Really into this blonde women plus like tomatoes, I guess
Yeah Whatever I don't think they're VTuber fans
There's no way they're VTuber fans guys, I'm willing I am willing to like I'm willing to risk it.
It's all I'm willing to gamble it all Let's go gambling.
This is a really really big fan of this particular blonde woman Um, yeah that the probability seems the probability seems skewed to my way I believe guys I believe in the probability Yeah, I'm pretty sure the cleaners have seen worse things there's no way they I'm pretty sure they've seen worse Hey,
there's no way I like there's no way
Uh, where's my super chats, uh Ink thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you rookies.
It's a work in progress I told you I stopped half a year ago.
I have a year ago.
I didn't even put everything up I was like, I was just thinking like oh man I can I'll like I might move in it.
I might move move soon So like what's the point and then I gave up I just cuz I cuz I'm always moving When I finally have a place, I'll stay for more than a year.
I will make a better shrine I will make a better shrine when I have a place that I'm staying for more than a year guy
Guys thing was super chatting.
Thank you.
I showed one of my colleagues at the doki the doki much I managed to get from a con last year Which was mostly still retro doki stuff and he really went Wow
I'm first name.
I think I'm seller moon.
You know what?
That's better.
They might have to be as famous as seller moon Oh my god You know what, I hope they think I'm seller moon and not a vtuber Because then at least like it's less doxable.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you All right, let's actually okay.
Let's actually play the game Yeah, my voice is like so I mean I should okay.
Should I just I'll do the after stream I'll just I was gonna say Should I just like Do that the words of the Chinese meds the black Chinese medicine I was wondering if I should just like get that in my I think I would sound so much better if I had it In my system right now.
Give me a sec guys.
I usually your throat land up a pie paper co-op I don't know how to actually pronounce it.
I'll be right back I think my voice would sound so much better at the moment.
It takes them.
I'll be right back guys
Back Nexy and that burns.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, I'm back guys Okay, I do sound a lot better.
All right, like I said, okay It's not gonna be a super long stream because I don't want to overdo it since I do have a cuz I won't be streaming The cloud by the way, I won't be streaming the cloud, but I will be showing up Um, it's like a repo collab and I remember who the other people Gumi invited,
but I haven't Gumi asked me to join her like a few days ago and I was like I can't but I can't I won't be there for long Though just so you guys know I won't be there for the repo collab for long.
I told her straight up.
I was like, um, I can't do it for too long Cuz I'm trying to rest my voice.
Um Anyway, um, what else I want to say?
Oh Yes, I actually looked up how long this game is and so like, you know, no I always do I would be like no commentary Playthrough of insert game here and then like I Pulled up the video and usually, you know those types of players They would they are like they they like play these games before so they think basically it's like the most concise way Playing the game.
So they're just like they don't usually make any errors or anything.
It's just they play the game throughout it To the point and then so, you know it's basically like they're usually a little faster and completing the game and stuff versus a regular player and Then so I was like, oh it can't be that bad because they're usually faster,
right?
so I Looked up the first video, which is the main video and it's not like faster but they like they're usually like a little faster than a regular person and I looked it up and this man's playthrough was 18 hours on and And I was like, where am I at I
Was like where am I at in this 18 hour long playthrough surely I'm closer to the 18-hour I'm surely I'm close like I'm in the middle, right?
I was at the 5-hour mark.
I
Was like, oh
Oh, I guess oh Okay We spent 18 hours on loop.
Yeah, so that that's not very I oh wait Wait, am I?
Wait, maybe I'm not guys.
No.
Oh my god.
Wait, let me double-check guys.
I need a note.
Where am I?
Oh my god, am I no
Okay, oh I'm at the oh, thank God.
Okay.
I'm actually at the 8-hour mark.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
I'm actually I'm actually at the 8-hour mark.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
I'm through.
I was three hours to her.
Okay I'm at the 8-hour mark.
It's not ideal though.
I saw Because we've done four parts of the series guys you guys are like, oh that's not too bad But let's count how many hours I've already spent on Dynasty Wars.
So I played three hours there I we've done this is part five.
I played three hours last time three.
I played another four So that's seven.
We're at okay, that's seven hours and then I played another four That's 11 hours and that played another three So I played 14 hours, but we're at the 8-hour part We're at the 8-hour part, but we've played for 14 hours, so it's not very ideal again We're not a very good pace.
We're completing Dynasty Wars, but we'll try our best Alright Here we go We had to do five hours to balance it out Subtract 35 minutes expert for just chatting sections at the start of each stream That's true, but I don't talk 35 minutes on all of them Anton,
thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, let's see Am I supposed to go?
Oh I have to go back to the gate.
Oh, of course.
I'm so silly in the city province It's obvious you really enjoy this game and we like seeing you enjoy it.
Okay It's not just a yaoi moment I'm reformed now I'm reformed It's not that's not the only thing
Thank you for the super chat Nexie, thank you.
Thank you.
I'm reformed.
I'm a reformed Fujo.
Oh, hey Tau-Tau Are we going on a date as well?
You might be but I'm not
You said Lucas!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh my god!
No, we will stay in Luoyang.
The lords need calming and the city must be rebuilt You fool Yuan Shao.
Have you forgot?
Am I not killing him yet?
Oh, wait.
No, I haven't That felt like such a fucking long-ass war Do you not see the city in ruins?
People don't even know where their next meal will come from.
It's okay, they'll make more children Coalition forces are still exhausted after the battle at Hulao Gate.
Yeah, but they're exhausted too.
Enough pretentious talk What are you after Yuan Shao?
Isn't that obvious?
The Yellow Turbans and Dong Zhuo have driven the world further into chaos.
A worthy Individual must step up.
That's me!
He's talking about me!
Wait, I think he's talking about himself, guys
Wait a minute Not me?
To restore the land Wait a minute, it can't be So you aim for glory well above your station
I believe it Why is it me?
I literally beat up Liu Bu While using save states That doesn't matter guys, it's Liu Bu We need every advantage against him No soul should have to face the loss of their family or home in such a way We should prepare to enter Luoyang There may still be people who need help You can't do save states!
You saw what I went through!
There's no way you individually would be able to Fucking beat Liu Bu without save states There's no fucking way without checkpoints You cannot oof me There's no fucking way I wanna see a dragon fucking beat Liu Bu Without checkpoints You cannot oof me As a first try As like a first time fighting him too
Yeah and tell me how long it took you
Oof Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, I always start watching streamers at the most awkward time.
At moments, I heard the word fujo.
Yeah, and then tell me how long it took you without checkpoints.
Who's the other guy?
He looks so generic.
It's like, guys, who do you think the main character is in this story?
It's like one of those anime main characters.
Protagonist.
Guess which one's the main character.
Is that Yun Shao without his helmet?
Oh my god, put that thing back on, you posy.
He looks so weird when he's not pretentious as fuck.
He looks so generic without the pretentiousness.
Yeah, no, you can tell it's Liu Bei because of his ears.
That's like, but he does look generic without it.
Yeah, the helmet stays on.
And the green.
Yeah, there's a dress code, guys.
When you join a kingdom, you can only wear green, blue, or red.
If you do not do well- if you do not look good in green, well, I'm sorry, I guess-
It's the Power Ranger rules.
Do you really?
I think- yeah, he did.
He did have the seal.
Sun Jian had the seal.
Call for me when you need me.
I just wanna keep my connections open, you know?
Can't keep all my eggs in one basket.
Oh my god, boys!
Boys!
Please, there's enough doki to go around.
They're fighting over me.
Stop fighting, guys.
Oh, boys!
Boys!
Wow!
So popular.
Stop fighting, boys.
They're like, oh, they're talking so seriously about the fucking seal.
They're trying to discuss politics right now.
They're like, oh, silly boys.
They aren't even talking about you!
Calm down.
Okay, guys, enough about the Imperial Seal, guys.
I'm also here.
It's all coded word, guys.
When they talk about Imperial Seal, they're talking about me, guys.
Oh my god, Liu Bei, don't say that about yourself.
Say that later, cuz say that later when you lose.
When you lose it all.
This is actually your peak right now, Liu Bei.
This is his peak moment here.
Oh, they're asking my opinion?
Oh, shit.
Sorry, I was too busy watching.
Perhaps not.
I don't fucking know.
Maybe I should just give zero opinion.
Oh, yeah, I forgot.
Left Doki.
Sorry, I keep forgetting Left Doki has to exist here.
Alright, alright, you see that?
Alright, Left Doki's here.
Every time another Doki appears, one has to be destroyed, so say goodbye to Right Doki.
Her existence is no more.
Oh, sorry, it glitched out.
Right Doki was like, no, don't delete me!
I refuse to be deleted.
Sorry, now she's deleted.
Alright, I don't know what she wanted to say.
Keep Right Doki, but make it too late.
She's gone now.
Alright, remain silent.
You're right, I shouldn't give my opinion.
I should just let the boys have their thing.
To me, though, both of you appear to have the qualities needed for such a task.
Quintess, you blinked out and died like an old-school JRPG character.
Yeah, the snab-like claws, the flicker of death.
Anyway, I should depart.
I am sure my camp is tired of waiting for me.
Then allow me to see you off, Lord Sun Tien.
What the fuck, little boy?
Don't do that.
Oh, what the fuck?
It's not time to get high right now.
What do you mean?
You guys didn't know the story- how the kid appears?
It's when the, um...
It's when- what is it called?
The incense?
The incense gets, like, way too much and then I see the little boy.
So I'm like, who the fuck lit up the funny incense?
Oh, shit, dragoons.
You're right, sorry.
I didn't realize some of you guys are still alive because I sent a lot of you guys to Lu Bu.
Really?
After I sent you to Lu Bu?
Oh my god.
We live.
Well, in my- my death.
We are very hard to kill.
I mean, to be fair, I thought, like, I had more of you guys.
But we did just came back from trying- killing Lu Bu.
So, like, I think I lost, like, 90% of my army.
I'm pretty sure.
Like, it's like the bacteria thing.
You know, it kills 99% of bacteria.
I think you guys were the 1% that lived.
Um, there's only 4 left.
After I sent us all to, like, to Lu Bu.
So...
Uh, we had to get rid of the weaklings.
The five remaining dragons.
The Fab Five.
There's five of them now!
Sun Jian was the first to lead the coalition, followed by Cao Cao.
Finally, even Zhang took his lead with Lu Bei.
Soon enough, mutual suspicion among the noblen devolved into outright squabbling.
The coalition formed to defeat Dong Zhuo came to a faltering end.
Alright, dragons.
Who do we call the- the last remaining five dragons that survived the great Lu Bu attack?
What's this?
It's time to camp.
Yao Chen, what?
The unlucky one.
The Gouda gang.
What the fuck, you fucking tried to kill me!
Goodbye.
Why am I talking to- she literally tried to 1v1 me.
Oh, thank God.
I don't want to meet her again.
I have made sure of that.
What do you mean?
I went to Chang'an with Dong Zhuo, and I saw the destruction.
No crawls allowed.
Is what I knew.
To kill a beast that has bested all men, I need to unleash an even bigger beast.
Oh, Lu Bu.
I will use myself as bait to pit Lu Bu against Dong Zhuo.
Oh no.
No matter what happens, I cannot allow the strategy to fail.
I can't believe you would do that to yourself.
Dating Lu Bu, the greatest man during the Three Kingdoms era?
What a fucking criminal act you're doing right now.
Oh no.
The strongest fucking man out there during Three Kingdoms.
Oh, what a sacrifice to humanity.
It should have been me, not her.
Don't go.
I'm not.
No, go alone.
Jealous much?
Oh no, what a great sacrifice you're making.
It's so disgusting to have to date Lu Bu.
Wow, Jesus Christ, the size differences between those two.
I'll make your dream a reality.
Wow, and he's a gentleman?
Wow, Diao Chan.
Truly, you should look for someone else.
Wow, oh my god.
I can't believe you could do something so disgusting and be a gentleman.
What is he doing?
Someone's... how terrible, what a sacrifice.
Oh?
Where did she come from?
He was there first.
Lu Bu led first.
How did she get there before him?
It makes no sense.
Oh!
Wait, he still has his head.
Okay, yeah, he's dead.
Rip the Dong.
Goodbye, Dong.
That's it, they just killed him.
The Dong was cut.
Wait, that's it?
That's how he's gonna die?
That felt so anticlimactic, the big Dong himself.
Oh my god, we finally finished chapter two.
Why is Sun Jian like the main character for this part?
He dies like...
He dies like in one more fight.
He's not even supposed to be part of the Three Kingdoms, he was not there.
Why did they put him in the center?
In the other games, he literally dies after two fights.
Get a little spoiled, Ace.
Let him have his moment, this is his one time.
Spoilers!
I'm sorry that this happened like how many hundreds of years ago?
Spoiler for a 1,500 year old book.
Okay, any interesting news?
Lords from somewhere or other looking for soldiers and such?
I don't know much about it, but I think it must have something to do with that great battle at the capital and whatnot.
So how are things around here?
We've had people who lost their land and homes down south, making their way up here.
I've also got a strange feeling that I'm hearing more talk of bloodshed than usual.
These are dark times we're in, indeed.
Are there any fan mail for me?
Yay!
More dragoons to recruit into my army!
It's Keilupu's guy.
Guys, you'll survive this time.
I don't have anything else to ask.
Thank you, Mr. Exposition.
Yay, fan mail!
Alright, let's see what kind of fan mail I got, guys.
Oh man, the incense.
I saw the incense, guys.
You see this shit, little boy?
My doctor boy.
Child be gone.
I mean, he is gone.
Alright.
Wait, that's not my dragoons.
Aw, come on, man.
Why?
You're right here!
You can just tell me!
You and Hua.
Alright.
Zilong, your knife hand technique is very impressive.
Just the other day, we all died.
There's not a lot of dragoons left alive to write you fan mail.
Doki.
Just the other day, when you noticed the cooking knife was rusty and there wasn't a spare in sight, you sliced the radish, cleaning with your hand, and then you made short work of a huge turnip where you see, while even thinking to fetch a cleaver.
Where did you learn to do that?
It was- This isn't even a report about my health!
He's just glazing me up.
Like, what the fuck?
It was a magnificent show of skill.
It's one thing- I thought you were here to observe my health!
Um...
You seem to naturally intuit the perfect place to slice, or what it looks like to me, anyway.
Perhaps somehow you were close to in the past also have the skill.
And with luck, perhaps some clues will take us closer to restoring your memory.
He is observing me way too much.
Not Doki, it's been too long.
Come to the usual place!
Oh my god, guys!
Guys, I got a date tonight!
Oh my god!
I got a date with God Knee!
Come to the usual place!
This one's on me!
My men are cool!
You're inviting more people?
They all wanna hear what you've been up- Woah, God Knee, you fucking freak!
Woah!
Suddenly, they're all your biggest fans!
Anyway, we're waiting.
I hope- okay, Sima Hui.
I heard there was a great battle near the city, and that you played no small part in it.
Now I have something I wish to tell you, so come visit my retreat!
When you have the chance, I think I can help you with- No, best explain in person.
I think I'll be waiting.
Oh my god!
Oh man, they're all pirates, dude.
God Ning and his crew.
You got a unitized dragon, then she'll take care of our lives.
That's not so dead- Well, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Oh damn!
Alright, we'll go to God Ning first.
Then I'll go to our usual place.
Wherever the fuck that is.
Where the fuck is our usual place?
Is that God Ning?
No, that's Zhuo Chang.
Where the fuck is God- Bro, where is my usual place?
How can you not rem- Jokey, how can you not rem- Okay, we'll just go visit Sima Kui first.
How do you guys remember the usual place?
Wait, Pang Tong?
Pang Tong?
What are you doing here?
I wasn't supposed to meet you yet.
Why are you wearing green?
Why are you wearing green yet?
The kingdom hasn't started.
Yes.
You've formed into a stronger Fuzhou.
Thank you for the super chat, Kaz.
Thank you, thank you.
Clearly he wasn't concerned as he told me to run the place the way I see fit.
But he also mentioned that you were a special guest.
To be treated with our utmost hospitality.
Spencer, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You should know, we guys take our bros relationship to the- Yeah, you guys remember where our usual special place is.
I was like, where the fuck is- I can't believe it, Jokey.
By the way guys, we met Gan Ning once, by the way.
And you guys were like, I can't believe it, Jokey.
I can't believe you would forget our special usual place that's down south.
That's really far away.
I'm like, how the fuck do you remember that?
And you- It's our bro's special place, Jokey.
Of course we'll remember it.
She'll never understand our bond.
Okay, I look for- Yeah, where is he?
It means nothing to you, so you don't remember.
Jokey doesn't understand the bro's code.
Oh, that's interesting.
They gave Peng Tong.
They're trying to make us bond with him before they killed him off.
That's fucked up.
That's so fucked up.
Like, he's gonna die and then he just won't be back here anymore.
Okay, I have so many people I have to talk to?
Help!
Okay, Gong- Okay, Jing Province.
Oh my god!
Boys!
Calm down, everyone!
Woah!
Is this a spoiler from the Invincible comics?
Is it?
Gong Ning.
Okay, Jing Province.
It's like the fucking...
People complaining about the fucking Invincible comics spoilers for the show.
Alright, let's go to...
Let's go to Jing Province first.
To our special place.
Yu Province.
Jing Province.
Woah, what the fuck, it's so far!
Wait, Lu Bu!
Woah!
We'll call Lu Bu later, okay guys?
Gong Ning sent us an actual letter.
Oh my god!
He made us dinner and everything?
Oh my god, like his crew are like his kids!
Like, Papa!
When will we see Papa Doki again?
Your really good friend Doki again.
You think so?
Papa!
Papa Gong Ning!
When will we see your really, really, really good friend?
Okay,
you think so?
Oh my god.
He's glazing me up, guys!
Your war pit buddy that you share your tent with!
Oh, you wanna settle down?
I mean...
Yeah, after this I have to meet up with Lu Bu and everything.
So...
I'm still not sure.
I didn't wanna talk about this.
But if not now, then when, right?
I got an invitation from Jing province.
See?
I ain't sure if I should accept it or not.
I don't even know the caliber of the guy who sent the invitation.
You fucking...
Okay, so like, if we're talking about like actual travel time.
I travel like, could've been traveling for one week.
Just to ask me what you...
Should accept the invitation or not.
Follow your heart.
Like, technically I could've been traveling for like an entire week.
I was on the other side of China.
And I had to travel to the...
And I had to travel to the other side of China.
To get to him.
And all he wants to ask me is like...
Should I take...
Should I say yes to this?
This could've been a fucking text message.
He is a single father.
She'll never understand.
Should I accept this job offer?
This could've been a text.
Follow your heart.
What seems best.
I really appreciate you.
Coming around.
To see me like this.
That's fine.
Well.
It'd be nice.
Some more time like this.
Send my boys on home.
At some point.
Oh, you're gonna send them home?
Oh my god!
Okay, it was worth it.
Oh!
Then we could enjoy some quiet time!
What the fuck!
Oh my god!
Oh shit!
Oh!
Some quiet time between you and all that!
There's no way!
Oh!
The fact that he was like.
I'm gonna send my boys home.
And then we could spend some quiet time.
You and me!
Okay!
That's not even subtle at all!
Guys!
That was not subtle!
That was straight up!
What the fuck!
What else would he be implying?
Chat.
Guys!
You cannot tell me!
There was any other implications there!
There was no!
What else would he be doing?
Quiet time!
Sorry!
Smash Bros with a bro, you know?
He just wanted to show his Bionicle collection!
Just wrestling!
Never a dull moment with you around!
These are chaotic times!
There's no telling what might happen to us!
Now I understand the context of that fujo statement earlier!
Thank you for the super chat!
Guys!
This has nothing to do with being a reformed fujo!
That was not subtle!
What else could they be implying?
If I wasn't a reformed fujo, I would even imply that they did something!
Hey!
Make sure you keep training just in case you get caught up in something while I'm not around!
I don't want you to get hurt!
Baby!
Bro!
Where did the fucking gangning love interest came from?
Jesus Christ!
I was not ready for that!
I was not ready for that, guys!
Oh my god!
When were you getting hurt, babe?
Oh shit!
Oh my god!
I got more!
We're waiting for you!
Jesus Christ!
It's been a while since last we met!
Chaochao has brought many new talents under his command!
Oh my god!
I have to pick!
It's given the order for us to take the field in Yang Province and we're very pissed if you could lend us your strength in this battle.
If you're interested, come- Why did Chaochao not send a letter?
Why was it Xiaohudun that sent- Oh my god, Chaochao, you tsundere!
Everyone else sent me a letter except for you guys!
Maybe Xiaohudun really wanted to talk to me, though.
We're waiting for you!
Okay.
How you been lately?
My days are so busy that I'm having a tr- What an interesting harem anime.
Osni, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
If they were doing a deed, it wouldn't be a very quiet time.
Thank you for the super chat, Osni.
Thank you, thank you.
Hot warlords in your area- single hot warlords in your area right now must be tired of watching me because all they talk about is wanting to see you!
Oh, bro!
Okay, sorry.
If the feeling is mutual, come on over and pay us a visit.
My sworn brothers and I are looking forward to more fun times.
Bro!
Whoever- Whoever did the localization for the English, I- Oh my god, people were saying the Japanese and the Chinese version of this game was also very similar.
I-
Soon - yeah.
Oh my god.
Can you come- I haven't even fucking actually played the game yet.
We're just- I'm fucking playing a visual novel right now.
Can you come to Nyang Nyang as soon as you read this?
We've gotten ourselves into a entire situation and we welcome your strength and our struggle to break through of it.
You'll have to wait until we can speak in person for more details.
I am certain that we can- Okay, Soon-Chi-En is normal.
He's normal.
He's actually been normal.
Paladin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You know what's crazy?
This entire time, we have not fought one battle yet.
The downtime fight has left more time for the pros.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Not so Deadpool.
And here we see a Pharaoh Fujoki bird in her natural habitat watching how she guides the Ikemen together effortlessly.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
Alright, we gotta go through our other routes right now.
Des knew what they were doing.
God, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
There's so many men.
So many routes.
I don't know which one to pick.
They all want a piece of me.
Not yet.
I've made up my mind.
Sun Jian.
Liu Bei.
Is there anyone worthy of being called a true hero?
In time, they are certain to clash with one another.
When that happens...
Oh, I'm picking Liu Bei.
I'm picking Xu, by the way.
I'm doing Liu Bei.
Your decision will set the course of our future.
Only for my Oshi Zhuge Liang.
And those who take the wrong path, just as Zheng Zhao and Dong Zhuo.
That's the only reason why I'm picking him.
And to see Peng Tong die again.
I want you to show me the choice you've made.
What do you mean boring?
People are ruining...
Initially, you can assist any of the three vows.
However, when you reach a pivotal point in history, you will no longer be able to fight alongside a hero if you have not made enough contributions to your cause.
As history has written, the heroes may come into conflict with one another.
When this happens, you must side with a faction, after which you will be unable to assist the faction you did not choose.
Listen to your dreams, watch your actions, and decide which one...
will be able to bring peace to the realm.
Everyone... That is not true.
Everyone picks Cao Cao more, I'm pretty sure.
I feel like Cao Cao has a better...
Definitely has like...
Lu... Xu...
Lu Bei has better...
Lu Bei has better heroes because like for some fucking reason...
For some reason, like...
Kouei loves Lu Bei.
They love Xu.
And they always... They put... They put all their efforts in designing the best character designs and the best, like... The best, like character designs and putting every...
Like everybody's Xu in the front...
Like in the front.
But I think Wu has better history.
Also, Lu Bei... Lu Bei's a fuckhead.
He's like... What's the word called?
He's a fucking poser.
He's always so discreet.
It actually makes him memorable.
Okay.
I don't know how to explain Lu Bei.
He's like...
He's like a deadbeat.
I think... Is that... Is that a better way to explain it?
He's like actually like a deadbeat where he does nothing.
But he has... He has the best generals.
He has the best generals, the best strategists, and he does nothing with them.
Because all he does is talk about fucking benevolence.
That's all he does.
Okay, where's Lu Bu?
I talked to Lu Bu.
He's a fraud.
He's a... He's not a netbo... Netbo baby because he was born poor.
He's just incredibly...
He's incredibly lucky, but he does nothing with his luck.
Where the fuck is Lu Bu?
Where's Lu Bu?
I'm gonna travel here to figure out where Lu Bu is.
Oh, wait, what?
Where's your super chat, Ava?
Let me check.
Ava, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's why...
That's why I didn't read it.
Hi, this is my main account for now.
Had better memories last year than I can express and looking forward to making new memories.
Thank you for the super chat, Ava.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, let's figure out where Lu Bu is.
Is your reputation not bad when you say it?
Alright, where is Lu Bu?
He is at Shu Province.
Okay.
Alright.
Where is Shu Province?
Or...
Oh, there it is.
Why does it show Lu Bu?
Where is he?
I wanna talk to you.
Is that him?
I think that's him.
That has to be him.
Yo, that's just a regular man.
The fuck is he?
I'm at... Okay, I'm back at Jin.
Wait, the fuck?
You said it was at you, right?
Wait, no, that's Shu.
Okay.
I'm so confused.
Where is...
Oh, it's right here.
Okay.
It's this way.
Guys, I don't know my east in my...
I don't know my east here.
Where the fuck?
Where is it?
Is it here?
Yo, that's Jin.
Oh my god.
I'm so lost.
Guys.
Oh my god, there's Xi Bi.
Guys, I'm so lost.
I'm so...
Oh, it's locked?
No!
They're preventing me from...
They're preventing my Lu Bu route.
That's so fucked.
Why would you prevent me from...
having my Lu Bu moment?
That's so messed up.
You are not allowed to pursue him.
Thank you for the super chat, Alcarin.
Thank you.
Will you do all the...
Your very first super chat.
Thank you.
Will you do all the faction stories or just one?
Tao Tao's objectively... I want to do all of them.
I'll be doing all of them, but I'm doing...
Lu Bei's first because...
Just for my Oshi, Zhuge Liang.
Zhuge Liang.
He's my Oshi.
And he's like my favorite character in the entire Three Kingdoms.
So...
That's why I want to do his first.
Tao Tao's objectively the...
correct choice, but it's up to you.
As for the Sun Clan, Sun Qian's route isn't lewd at all.
I'm not joking.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, because she gets fucking married to Lu Bei.
She's a taken...
girl.
You do not look friendly.
You look like you're about to...
fucking backstab me...
at any moment.
Break from what?
Why me?
Oh.
Yeah, but even...
But he's actually not friendly.
He's backstabbed people.
He's actually not even friendly.
Even though he doesn't look like it.
He says he's friendly.
He actually backstabs people.
Learn when you was defeated?
He has friends.
Just friends.
Ambitious people like them...
always assume everybody else thinks...
the same way they do.
So in their minds...
anyone not demanding promotion...
for their achievements, like me...
is suspect.
So the more work I do...
the less I'm trusted.
Still, writing that out...
is also part of being a tactician.
Then get your promotion.
Just to be less suspectable.
Making me spill my story like that.
I said one thing.
You just kept talking.
That's what I said!
Okay, no.
I shouldn't say that.
That was in for us.
I just said one thing.
Oh my god.
I hope you say yes.
Whoa.
I have so much res, I don't even need to try.
Guys, I haven't been in my first battle yet.
There's so many men...
asking for me.
I'm so popular, guys.
I'm so popular.
I literally...
have yet to...
progress.
Because I have so many...
routes to do.
Okay, Yang.
No, that's Li province.
Okay, there we go.
Alright, Li Dian.
Oh my god.
There's the queue.
I have to go through my queue right now.
He wants to text the Confucius.
Wait, what's the November pop-up smurf?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Who was that elderly man?
That was my teacher.
He's an incredible man.
Apparently, he taught history and military strategy in the capital.
We met when I was looking for manuals on military doctrine.
And we just really related well to each other.
Just earlier, we were speaking about a particularly rare tome.
And as you heard, she got a little excited.
She got a little excited.
I don't want to play this in November.
I love it.
I have some interest.
I wasn't expecting so much romance.
It's literally called Romance of the Three Kingdoms.
I just think they forgot the definition.
They just didn't realize they got the other definition of romance.
They got confused on which romance it was.
Bro, this man's hair.
Gel in ancient China goes hard.
Oh, we could read together?
Read together?
Yeah, wait.
I was like, yeah, let me...
I'm sorry, bro.
I'm sorry.
Oh, I didn't mean to mess up the choice.
I just thought it was funny.
What did you mean?
What do you mean me?
And let's study together.
Oh my god, he's getting closer!
Yeah, friends.
He took like a step closer and I got scared.
I was like, personal space.
Oh my god.
My second Oshi.
Cheng Liao.
They were also roommates.
I'm afraid of commitment.
It's me!
Yeah, I killed you.
Now that you mention it.
Oh no, you fucking kicked my ass.
Oh no, of course I did.
Oh wait, we're getting closer.
No, don't leave!
Leave!
How big is your room when you have this many roommates?
Enough for China.
We're tired for all the generals in China.
I fight to help others.
Liu Bu?
Why do you serve Liu Bu?
After all, he betrayed even the oath he swore with Dong Zhuo, his adoptive father.
But Lord Liu Bu is the greatest warrior to have ever lived.
Fighting under him is an honor.
And I feel no shame in serving him.
I am committed to my lord and I would give my life for him.
That is my purpose in life.
Apologies.
I have taken up too much of your time with my wayward children.
But I have enjoyed this talk.
You have my thanks.
As souls of the battlefield in this game, may we meet again.
As allies or as enemies.
When that day comes, I will show you what I am capable of.
I wish you well until then.
Hmm.
Alright.
Twin Peaks.
We will meet on the battlefield.
Alright.
There's more!
I see you!
Oh my god!
There's so many people that want to talk to me!
It's been snooping around here.
Please!
There's only one of me!
Who is this guy?
I recognize him.
I don't remember which faction he's in though.
A new one?
No?
Who are you?
Was this the guy?
Oh, this is Oshie's squad.
Oh!
Three streams ago!
Oh my god, that's him three streams ago!
That was like a month ago.
What?
Oh my god, wait.
What the fuck?
Wait, what?
This isn't even Bro anymore.
Wait...
I think...guys...
I don't think there was a no homo there.
I think...
This is not just an Oshie anymore.
Guys, he didn't end it with no homo!
He didn't!
That was real!
Wait...
I guess I can...
Wait, you're not even here for me?
He wasn't even here for me!
Bro, he wants my roommate!
What?
Not everyone is here for you, Doki.
But I'm the main character!
Bro!
He came over here to tell me he's not interested?
That's fucked.
That's so fucked.
I wanna take this.
Okay, who is she?
Wait, there's another woman!
Wait, who is she?
Oh my god, the second- the third woman in this game!
Who is she?
What?
Me?
Why?
Shouldn't you find your mate?
Wait, what?
I don't recognize her.
Shouldn't you find your mate?
Yeah, that's right.
Begone!
Oh my gosh, she Uno-reversed me.
My lady, this area isn't exactly dangerous, but I don't advise walking alone.
It'd be best to rely on him for help.
He's a renowned warrior.
Oh, is that right?
Then it seems my impression was not mistaken.
Would you be so kind as to escort me then?
I must give you a little reward.
Oh, a reward?
Oh, my lady, say less.
Did I accept?
Alright, do I accept her?
Do I be a simp and accept, or be like, what about your mate?
Fuck it, I accept.
I'm grateful for your help.
Now, let's set off.
A simp!
I'm truly grateful for you today.
That was my first time fully exploring the town.
I thought I was escorting you!
Why are we...
Did you enjoy...
Why did we explore?
I thought we were taking you home.
That's a very nice man.
Now move, I'm here for the man.
Mr. Stan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Did you enjoy it?
Can we find your maid?
It truly feels like a stroke of luck to have met you.
I am so very glad that I snuck out of our residence.
Snuck out?
Wait, so there was no maid!
Yes, it's as you suspect.
I lied about being separated from my maid.
Liar!
She lies about this.
What else would she lie about?
Oh my gosh, she's like Jasmine.
Oh, they're fucking rich as hell.
You should.
The world is vast, with so much to see, and so much to adore.
And yet, when I marry into the Yuan family, I will be in another cage, only more lavish than the one I am in now.
Yeah, but do you not see all the gold that he wears?
No, you don't want to go out there.
People are literally dying of starvation.
She does not know how bad it is out there.
I saw drag queens fucking die in Kuala Lumpur.
She doesn't fucking know.
She's been living so sheltered and was like, oh man, I wish I could live out there where people are dying from starvation and poverty and are starting to cannibalize others.
Oh man, that's where I'm gonna be free.
You don't know what it's like out there.
I've been in non-stop war, ma'am.
I...
Oh my God.
Call for me again if you'd like.
We walked outside.
Oh my God, that's Chen Ji?!
Wait, isn't...
Wait, that's Chen Ji?!
No way!
I thought she'd be, she should be like younger!
She's, she's Chow Chow's son's wife.
She shouldn't be alive!
Wait, no, she is supposed to be alive.
But she's supposed to be like a child!
I did not realize, I had a feeling it was uh, I had a feeling that was Chen Ji but I was like, no, she's wearing yellow.
Because like, you know, we saw Pang Tong wearing a green already, you know?
I saw, we saw Pang Tong uh, wearing green, so I was like, oh, okay, so they're all gonna be wearing their faction's colors.
And, and so like, seeing Chen Ji in white and yellow messed me up, cause I was like, cause like, Chen Ji always has the mole on her, like, underneath her right eye.
So I was like, oh, that has to be Chen Ji, right?
But then I was like, no, she's not wearing blue.
But then like, I was like, oh man, okay.
And also I was like, there's no way it's her, because like, she's supposed to be Chow P's wife.
So I was like, there's no way that's her.
And then I was, and then now she's like, I'm Chen Ji.
And I was like, oh yeah, I forgot they aged everybody up and like, his, like, nothing is like, like, time is just, like, messy right now.
Time is not a straight line at the moment.
It's like everybody is somehow just in their late 20's for some fucking reason.
Okay, I'm gonna use the bathroom, guys.
I'll be right back.
Like, time is relative.
We don't know, it's all an illusion.
It's man-made.
I'm back.
But that's, it's so crazy.
She's like, I wish I could be free.
And I'm like, there's literally a famine going on right now in the middle of all this war.
What the fuck do you mean you hate this life?
Like, anybody would trade their fucking, like, they would trade like, their arms and legs to be like you right now.
That's like crazy.
Alright, let's see.
She's kind of, yeah, just a little sheltered, guys.
Just a little bit.
How much more do I have to talk to?
Alright, the silly province.
Alright, gotta go to the silly province real quick, guys.
Alright, where's the silly province?
Shoot.
Where is it?
Where's my favorite little silly guy?
Alright, there you go.
Flaming, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, there you go.
Alright.
Wait, do I have to do this?
This mini one?
I'll just do this mini quest.
Okay.
Okay, just a general.
Oh my god, our first fight, guys!
Oh my god!
Our fucking first fight, everybody!
I actually sort of don't remember how to play, though.
Like, this is a little bit...
Okay.
Okay, it's fine.
I figured it out.
I just have to do this.
There you go.
Oh, nice!
Counter!
Oh my god, we did it!
Okay.
Okay, nice.
And then we do our... Why, why, why, why, why?
Jesus Christ, you're so fucking strong!
Guys, at this rate, this is gonna be, like, this could be, like, the only fight we do at this point.
Imagine this is, like, our only fight we do because of...
Because we were stuck in a visual novel.
For, like, almost two hours.
Okay, nice.
We did it.
You don't understand, it's the lore.
Yay!
Oh, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you!
Guys, this is, like, literally the first fight I was in.
I forgot about the gameplay.
I was so locked in.
Okay, I did it.
I did the thing.
Talk to me.
What the fuck?
What?
Was this not the quest?
I did the wrong one.
I did the wrong one!
This was what I was supposed to do!
Quest, okay.
Now I'm done.
Now this is the right one.
Oh my god.
How was I supposed to know?
It was right next to him!
Okay, that's fine.
I figured it out, guys.
Okay, this is the right guy.
Alright, nice.
Okay, goodbye.
We'll make it fast.
That's fucking right.
Get over here.
Nice, okay.
I still have the Y.
That's good.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Look, it just happens, okay?
Look, my brain was muddied by like the side quests, alright, guys?
You can't blame me, alright?
I got distracted by the side quests.
Alright, we- Oh wait, there's more.
There's a wise rebel general.
Oh, he fucking missed.
I got distracted, okay?
I got distracted.
It could happen to any of you!
Okay, we did it.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
Looking rough.
Alright, nice.
Yay, we did it!
Looking rough.
Alright, now I did your thing.
If I'm not mistaking, you must be- Ah, I suppose it would be rude to pry.
Let's leave it at that for now, but someday, I'll very much enjoy the chance to learn more about you.
Oh, okay.
Alright, where is the Lu Bu quest line?
I have no idea where Lu Bu- Lu Bei's forces is.
Is this Lu Bei?
I wanna do Lu Bei's stuff.
Oh, that's Sun Jian.
Wait, is there something here?
Oh, there's a weapon shop!
Where am I at?
I'm at 91.
Okay, I need, like, not weapon 91.
Okay, uh...
That is Sun Jian's camp, so...
Just follow the benevolence?
But where is the benevolence?
Okay, it's here.
It's right here.
This is Puyang Ping...
Okay, we'll go here, fast travel here.
Okay, one of these has to be...
Wait, which one's him?
Is it this one?
I don't wanna accidentally do the wrong one.
Okay, is it the one- no, that's blue, right?
That's green over there.
Oh, there's green over there!
Yeah, that's green.
Yeah, I saw the colors.
Okay, there you go.
That's blue bear.
If all else fails, look for the colors.
Oh my god, guys, we're progressing the story.
We're actually progressing.
Oh my god.
We're actually progressing, guys.
Let's be the only fight we do today.
After all that.
My apologies.
Oh my god, Guan Yun.
Oh my god.
You seem quite taken aback.
And the rest.
I admit, I haven't gotten used to this either.
Now that you're the governor, you must look, and more importantly, act the part, sir.
Oh my god.
Oh, he has his famous armor!
He finally has his Lupe armor!
Governor of Ping Yuan.
Oh my god.
He's so benevolent and dreamy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
War room with table meeting cutscene number 428.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I was summoned here because we once again need your help.
Yeah?
But I should explain the situation.
First, what happened after we parted ways in Luoyang.
We returned to You province with Lord Gongsun Zan.
And I was appointed as governor of Ping Yuan.
I think I'm doing a good job, if I do say so myself.
My work has been praised by others.
Your work or like your general's work?
Why are you doing well?
We have my brother to thank for all we've achieved.
Words of his deeds is beginning to spread across the land.
You shouldn't put me on such a pedestal, Guan Yu.
We have only done as well as we have because of Lord Gongsun Zan's support.
As we speak, our benefactor is under attack from Yuan Shao in Ji province.
I hear they're struggling.
I'm sure they would appreciate our help.
We owe a lot to Gongsun Zan.
What worth is there in life if you forget the kindness shown to you?
However, now that Yuan Shao has gained a foothold in Ji, he may be stronger than when he led the coalition forces.
Meanwhile, our army is still at his feet.
I just realized how short Liu Bei is.
I mean, Guan Yu is known to be super fucking tall, but he's like a good meter taller than him.
Short King.
Him and Tata are the definition of Short King.
Hello, baby man.
Yeah, is that fair?
Being like beside Guan Yu right now?
Oh my god, our first fight.
We're gonna do it.
88...
80... Okay, I wanna... Let's see what my actual objective... Okay, where's the Shao Dun objectives?
Okay, charge strong attacks.
Okay, battle arcs using the Pudao.
Okay, I just gotta...
If I complete this, everything will be fine.
Do I have the Pudao?
Where is it?
Oh, there it is.
What's my strongest one though?
Do I have a level 80?
I don't know if I have a level 80 one.
Oh, I have a level 89.
Alright, we're gonna try and do it with...
We're gonna try and do it with this.
Anybody look short next to Guan Yu.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's true though.
That is very true.
Rising.
Thank you, thank you.
Except for Lu Bu.
Alright.
Alright, first...
It might be only battle we do today.
To progress the fight story.
Ninja, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guan Yu and Lu Bu.
It's just Tokyo, man.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Engage in combat at...
Both forces are quite large, so the battle will likely be fierce.
We need to help him, but we can't afford to do too much.
If we lose you, brother, it will be all for nothing.
You make a fair point, which is why I'll be grateful to have you all watching over both of us during this battle.
Judging by the formation, most of the fighting will be done in the center.
Lord Guan Xun Zhang must want to break through their front line.
They do have the cavalry on their side, such as an elite unit gives him a consistent advantage in a frontal assault.
He has no doubt planning to use them to charge through enemy lines, which means we should probably back up their offensive.
Okay.
But in hurrying their aid, we still have not seen a battlefield with our own eyes.
Our sister may yet elude us.
The gap in the enemy's central formation is especially suspicious.
Oh, it has to be a trap.
That has to be a trap there.
There's no way.
Why would they just leave it empty?
That's like a trap.
Like, I can see the trap from like 20 miles away.
Also, let me get water, guys.
I forgot to do that.
Fill my water before we go into our one and only fight after an hour of visual novels.
Alright, I got my water.
I'm ready.
I'm ready to play the game.
That overlooks the battlefield.
We'll see ourselves from there.
Okay, we should be going soon.
Alright, let's go.
Okay, I want Guan Yun.
Wait, no.
Why the fuck would I pick Zhang Fei over fucking Guan Yun?
Guan Yun is literally the god of war.
Zhang Fei died from like...
because he drank too much.
Zhang Fei is an alcoholic.
He died being known as an alcoholic while Guan Yun died and became a god of war.
Same.
Bro,
my grandma had a fucking shrine.
Like those like...
What's it called?
You know like the shrine offerings and stuff?
She had a fucking shrine offering for fucking for fucking Guan Yun.
I know who's important here.
Okay, nice.
How do I use the strong attack again?
Oh, I found it.
I figured it out.
I forgot like what exactly was like the benefit of offering doing offerings for Guan Yun.
Exactly.
No, it's actually because he became like he became like an actual like god.
Because of like he got like ascended into godhood.
It's like regular for like...
Is it business success?
Is it money?
I forgot what it was.
But there's a reason for... Oh, I opened the door.
Open the door!
Who is?
Zhao Yun?
Bro, you're supposed to be a fucking hero!
You literally have the fucking main character buff Zhao Yun.
What do you mean?
Okay.
Yeah, and where's Zhang Fei's shrine?
That's right.
Nowhere.
Okay, nice.
Just gotta kill this guy.
I don't know if I like this.
I don't like this weapon in general.
I'm only doing it so that I can romance Zhao Yun.
Look!
Look, I don't hide what the purpose was.
I'm not gonna lie.
Okay, nice.
Valor!
Look!
I'm not gonna lie of my true purpose of trying to use this weapon.
Alright.
Almost done.
Nice.
Counter.
Okay.
Nice.
Easy.
Okay, we gotta go this way.
Oh, they're ready to charge so we gotta help them.
Oh my god.
Zhao Yun has found an Oshi right now.
What if I just move forward?
What if I trigger the ambush right now?
That is so fucked!
I just triggered the ambush while they're in the middle of talking.
Alright, nice.
Do I do this again?
I DRAGONS FIRE!
Oh, I fucked it up.
Whoops.
Sorry guys.
I fucked up our charge!
Because I sent in arrows too late.
Whoops.
My bad.
I fucked up our charge, guys.
Oh!
I messed up!
I messed up the plan!
Sorry, instructions were definitely unclear for me.
What exactly what he wanted.
That's my bad.
I take full blame in that.
Oh, shit!
Nice.
Forgive you, commander!
Whoops.
Yeah, I'm sorry, guys.
Sorry, that was my fault.
That was absolutely my fault.
I fucked it up.
The moment cost you your place in... Oh, shit!
I have no bug slash?!
Oh, give me a sec!
I'll be right back.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Sorry, I fucked it up.
I was not paying attention.
Oh, shit.
Let me get some buns real quick.
I didn't even realize I used up all my buns.
Buns!
Guys, professional general here?
Okay.
Okay, that's five.
Tactical retreat, guys.
Okay, we gotta kill this guy.
No, no, no!
You're not kill stealing!
I spent so much trying to kill this guy!
Nice!
Oh my god!
Oh, shit!
Jesus Christ!
I spent so long trying to kill this guy!
Nice!
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Let's get the...
We need to go grab the house real quick.
Grab the fort back.
I'll grab here first.
Okay, how much more do I have to do for Chahut?
Okay.
Okay, completed that.
I just need to do the charge attack thing.
Alright, get over here!
Let me swap weapons first.
No!
Wait!
Wait, I'm not good with this weapon!
No!
Let me swap my weapon in this 1v1!
Okay, nice.
Okay, I'm glad he lets me swap my weapons in this 1v1.
I really appreciate that.
In the middle of the 1v1, like...
Too late!
Oh my god!
Thank god he lets me swap it.
In the middle of 1v1ing.
There we go.
Oh my god, it's like I actually know how to use this weapon.
It's like...
Give me a sec!
I gotta use this real quick!
I'm just like...
Men!
Men, pass me my actual weapon!
There we go.
That should be done now.
Okay, and then we get our fort back.
Alright, nice.
Get out of here!
Oh shit, a lot of people are dying right now.
That is bad.
Look, this is very important!
You don't understand!
Okay, nice.
Wait, are we not claiming the base back yet?
This is for Shaohun Dun!
You don't understand!
I need this!
Okay, have I completed yet?
Nice, okay, now I'm free.
Now I'm free.
Oh shit, that's not what I wanted.
I'm back to this.
Okay, now we actually...
Okay, who do we...
Okay, we gotta help these guys over there.
Yeah, I wanna help.
But how do I get there?
Okay, we gotta get this base.
Zhang Fei, please.
This is why you're not remembered in history, Zhang Fei.
Okay, nice.
Bro, Zhang Fei, how the fuck did you lose to them?
I just finished killing all of them!
Okay, nice.
Nice.
Nice, alright.
That's right!
Oh my god, behold your fucking power!
Nice, we did it.
Counter.
Okay.
Oh my god, this game gets so much easier when I can actually...
When I'm using a weapon I actually know how to use.
Holy shit.
How is there more?
Okay, fuck it.
Let's go duel.
Let's duel.
Where?
Where is he?
What am I dueling with?
That bugged out?
You?
Wait, you don't want to duel anymore?
You don't want to fight anymore?
I literally...
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe he didn't want to duel with me anymore.
That's so fucked.
Did I cancel it?
What?
Oh, I must have...
That's an accident.
That was actually an accident.
I did not mean to cancel the duel.
Fuck it, let's go.
He didn't want to...
Alright, he came back.
That's good.
That's fucking right.
You're gonna start it off with that?
Buddy!
That was so predictable, buddy.
I can't believe you started out with that as your duel.
Oh my god.
Embarrassing yourself in front of your entire men like that?
Get fucking...
Get down.
That's fucking right.
I'm gonna take my fort back too.
I'm gonna take it back.
I'm gonna back my house.
God damn it, John Fenn.
You lost to this, John Fenn?
How did you lose to this?
Oh my god, go...
Is that what Fenn even held his own?
Come on, buddy.
Come on.
Even Lu Bei got his shot.
Nice, we got it back.
Nice.
Oh my god, and he killed two!
He got a twofer!
John Fenn.
God damn it, John Fenn.
This is why everyone wants you.
You can solo.
He's actually holding his own.
That's crazy.
Okay, before we get to Dao Yun, let's just help Lu Bei real quick on the side.
Alright, Lu Bei, don't worry, I got you.
Don't worry.
Wait, they're all dead.
Wait, there's no one else in...
Wait, he killed everybody.
Oh wait, there they are.
I was like, where are they?
I was like, where's the rest of the people?
I was like, wait, what?
Did you die?
Alright, here we go.
Let's start.
Let's go.
For Doki!
Before we get ambushed.
Oh wait, we don't get ambushed?
Oh shit.
Oh no.
Wait, I have an idea.
This is it.
It's time.
It's time for the real game now.
That's fucking right.
Where are you?
It's time to play the game for real.
That's right.
Get down.
We're playing the game for real now.
That's why your grandma prays to me.
This is right.
Millions of people pray for me for this reason.
That's fucking right.
Oh my god, that's so fucking embarrassing for you.
If you really think you can fucking kill me.
That's right, get out of here.
Oh yeah, that was a mistake for you.
Oh.
Nice.
I don't know what you're feeding him, but damn, he's fucking big.
That's why he ascended into godhood.
Yes, we did it.
That's literally like one of the reasons why he was just that good.
He eats freaks too.
Wait, I can do this again?
You know what?
I believe in you guys.
Alright, send your arrows.
Alright, standby.
Go send your arrows in.
There you go.
What the fuck, am I injured?
What do you think?
Bro, I had three people on my ass.
Yes, I'm injured.
Like, what do you mean am I injured?
Holy shit.
There's like three people on me right now.
Oh my god.
I'm trying to figure out where people are.
There's too many people.
Oh my god.
Where?
I can't tell.
There's so many.
There's so many!
What the fuck is going on?
I need to go.
Oh my god, please!
Please!
Holy shit!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I lived.
Oh my god, where?
What's going on?
What the fuck?
Oh my god, just challenge me.
Please.
Just challenge me.
It'd just be easier.
It'll actually be easier if you all just challenge me.
Please.
Oh my god, I'm DJing.
Okay, guys, guys, I actually have to go.
Oh my god.
Like, I'm scared.
I am so scared right now.
I'm actually I'm so scared.
Okay, that's okay.
Alright, now it's just a... Now this isn't even fair anymore for him.
Oh, thank god.
Thank god, now we're all just... Oh my god, that's crazy.
That is actually crazy.
Oh, that was so scary, guys.
Alright, yeah, you go help out.
I was living by a fucking thread.
I don't know how I survived.
The mosh pit.
That was actually a mosh pit right there.
Holy fuck.
You fought well, honorable foe.
I was like, where am I?
Holy shit, that was fucking scary.
Nice.
Yay!
Oh my god, I get to talk to Xiaodong again.
My god.
Alright, let's see.
Did we upgrade all of this?
Alright, we did.
Okay, I need to hold more items.
I'll... Enables you to perform an extreme musou attack?
What the fuck is extreme musou?
Guess we'll find out soon.
Can't wait to talk to Xiaodong.
Him?!
Thanks to him?!
What about me?!
I only did what any soldier would do.
I am simply happy to know that I managed to assist a man of such valor.
Where is me in this casine?
Why is this happening without me?
Where am I?
You've earned it after such a battle.
Farewell then.
This is the first time they have a cutscene without- No, there's the one where they murder Dong Zhuo.
I forgot.
Oh wow, he has an oshi now.
He's hooked.
He found an oshi.
He's trying to take my fourth brother's I'm not that whore!
I'm the fourth sworn brother!
Okay.
More Myers?
Of course.
Your brother- Huh?
What is he doing here?
You're supposed to be with Cao Cao.
We're blue.
What are you doing here in green territory?
This is a green lands for you, bluey!
Time is relative.
Everything is not in the correct order right now.
You're in the wrong neighborhood, bluey.
If we mobilized immediately, we would suffer severe losses.
And then we might struggle to defend our own land.
There's reason to that.
However, you would discard all compassion when faced with logic.
And, if I said I would.
Well then, Lord Kang Chong and the others are doomed to die.
Yeah, but then we're doomed to die.
You can't just fucking go in there and talk about virtue and benevolence to Lupe.
You know how he gets.
Oh my god, he pulled a virtue card.
That's fucked.
That's so fucked.
Every time you pull a virtue card, you can't say no.
He's killed true Tim.
I look tired.
That's been my life the last year.
I also did a stream.
I started a stream.
Every 1230 stream is how I am right now.
Alright, battle Kong Rong and Lupe forces versus the- Okay, Lupe.
How good are you at visit?
I'm very far too much to do and not enough hands to go around.
You're not the type to let a man down, right?
Rescued at the hands of Lupe.
This one?
What is this?
I can't be that bad.
Can I go to Lupe now?
Is it possible?
Okay, let's do this quest real quick.
We're in.
Help the peasants reach the escape point.
Where are they?
Are they following me?
Are these the peasants?
Why do these peasants have weapons?
Okay, is there anyone I wanna- Is there anyone that I wanna- Okay, defeat strong enemies with a spear.
Okay, you know what?
Since like- Since we're here.
What the fuck?
God Ning wants me to do four different things?
Okay.
Alright, fuck it.
Since we're here, we might as well get the God Ning objective.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, peasants, are you okay now?
Wait, the peasants- Oh, shit!
Oh, fuck.
Oh, they are.
Oh, fuck, they are.
Okay, I thought I was guiding them.
Wait, what?
How do I- Wait, what?
Oh, I went the wrong way.
Oh my god, please live.
I went the wrong way.
What?
Sorry.
Sorry, I went the wrong way, guys.
Oh my god.
Okay, well, we're saving the peasants.
Okay, as long as one peasant is alive, everything will be fine, guys.
Oh, fuck!
Oh!
Oh my god!
Don't worry, I got you, peasant!
I got you!
Oh, that's awkward.
That was awkward.
It's okay, he's still alive.
It's okay, they're still okay.
Nice.
I don't like this fear right now.
This fear.
He ate his bread, guys.
He's fine.
He ate his bread.
Nice.
Countered.
Come on, come on.
Oh, fuck, I didn't counter that, though.
Okay, I countered that.
Jesus Christ.
Jesus Christ, I'm not countering anything!
He's so strong!
It's fine, I have bread.
Oh, he's so fucking strong!
How can I get a little bit here?
Okay, nice.
Nice, alright, got him.
Alright, he'll be fine now.
Okay.
Okay, so where do we take him?
Where's the escape point?
Okay, come with me, come with me.
It's literally right here.
Wait.
What are you doing?
Why are you scared?
Come on, go!
Go!
It's literally rightit's right here?!
Bro!
Okay.
He could've just ran.
It's like right here!
Hello!
Alright, we did it.
We saved this guy.
Okay.
I got...
six out of that.
Oh, okay, that's cool.
And thenoh, wait, no!
Okay, 43, 6...
I mean, ah, it's almost there.
We're almost there.
We saved the one guy.
We did it, Lube.
I saved one man.
Okay, nice.
You'll help me again if I ask, won't you?
I feel like I can always count on you.
Alright.
Now...
Wait, is this where Lu Bu is?
Is Lu Bu over here?
Okay, that's green.
Where is he?
Hello.
I worked so hard to be here.
Oh my god.
I can finally pursue Lu Bu!
Oh, it's me.
It's me.
Oh.
That was nothing unusual.
Oh!
I have his attention!
Hehe!
Oh my god, he noticed me, guys!
He noticed me!
Um...
It just turned out this way.
Oh.
Oh my god.
I'm so humble.
Oh.
Oh, and what do you want to do?
Hahahaha!
I suspect I do, Lu Bu.
Woah!
Woah, woah, woah, woah!
Woah, wait!
You're leaving?
Wait, don't leave!
Wait, no!
No!
Lu Bu!
Okay.
Deplete an enemy's fortune and activate him.
Why?
Wait, why?
Oh, I need to use the twin pikes.
You want to make good use of it.
Oh, goodbye!
Goodbye!
Hahahaha!
Oh my goodness!
Guys!
Guys, he noticed me, guys!
Oh my god, he noticed me!
Oh, woah!
Hahahaha!
Okay, what the fuck is Xiaohu doing?
I completed a stupid quest.
Okay, let's go here.
Don't hold back, Lu Bu.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Did I complete it?
Oh, I can pay for it?
Fuck it, let's pay for it.
Hahahaha!
Let's pay for it.
Fuck it.
I don't...
I have the money, I'm fine.
I'm fast-tracked.
I'm gonna fast-track it.
It's worth it, guys.
It's so worth it.
Trust me.
Didn't I finish all of Xiaohu's thing?
I did.
He just doesn't want to talk to me.
Okay, where is he?
I forgot how to get there.
Guys, I forgot how to get there.
Wait, how do I get there again, guys?
I don't remember.
Oh, it's here.
He should be back there, right?
Oh, I see him.
He should be here, right?
No, I'm lost.
Is he here?
No?
Okay, where is he?
Where is he?
Is he here?
Wait,
am I in?
Oh, I have a letter.
I have a letter.
Oh!
I better see you here!
Get here now!
And I will allow you to sit with me at my favorite eatery.
You have shown some semblance of confidence and battle.
For that, you will be fed.
Get ready.
Oh my god!
Wow, so forward!
Oh, we're so in!
Get ready to leave as soon as you're done reading this.
You do not want to keep me waiting!
Oh my god!
Oh!
Oh, he's so funky!
Okay, look, there's a letter from you guys.
I'd like to extend my gratitude for saving a caravan from the bandits.
I'm glad to see that you're fine.
Please allow me to explain why I'm writing.
This is the second time you have saved us.
I better see you here, kitten!
You went all the way to save us from the scoundrels.
Well, I'm sure he would be delighted to see you as strong as ever.
Please take this.
It used to belong to the guard.
I hope it will serve you well.
Okay, I don't care about all these other people.
We gotta go to Lu Bu.
I'll talk to them later.
He's waiting for me to pursue him, chat!
Okay.
Alright, where is he?
Guys, we have to get there now.
Oh my god.
I'm ready to hear the secret chat.
Alright, let's head over.
Oh, I see him.
I see the big handshake in the sky.
We can't keep him waiting, chat.
We can't keep him waiting.
Hello?
Why is this game like this?
Luke!
Donkey!
This is important!
Okay.
Oh.
Okay, guys, guys, guys.
What do I do?
They satisfy me enough or it doesn't matter that much.
Guys, no satisfaction.
No satisfaction.
Second one?
Second, okay.
Oh.
He's so cool.
I won't tell DL Chan.
I honed my skills and silenced my adversaries with brute force.
Then, I took to the battlefield and demonstrated my worth time and again.
In short order, all who opposed me had vanished.
The ones who remained extolled my martial prowess with abject devotion.
Anyone can speak of morality and compassion.
But, these will never come to pass with mere rhetoric alone.
Even the scoundrels and schemers desire the strength to triumph under any circumstance.
Am I wrong?
Oh my... Fuck, guys!
Oh!
Do I not agree with him or do I just be like, I don't know.
I'm just a dumb warrior.
Two?
Okay, two, okay.
Indeed, I expected you to refute me, given all your deeds and having saved so many lives.
I cannot comprehend you.
I'm a mystery to him!
How is it you've come face to face with death over and over, yet you side with those who are all talk?
You should know that bravado and ambition rot with you in the earth when you leave this mortal coil.
And those who will take to the battlefield shielded by the strong and perish as their hollow prattle fails them.
The notion of a world filled with such rabble makes me sick.
I will stand above all things and teach all the men and women of the world that might makes right.
Oh, fuck.
Guys, guys, my wingmen!
Guys!
Only the strong think such things.
Not everyone can be so...
Guys, what choice do I make?
Two?
One or two?
One?
Dragoons, wingman me right now!
Guys, this is a group effort.
So, in the end, if I get in with Lu Bu, we all get in with Lu Bu, guys.
We're all gonna be with Lu Bu, guys.
I'm doing it for us, chat.
Don't lie and say like you don't want Lu Bu.
Don't fucking lie.
It's a group effort.
It's a team.
We are all pursuing Lu Bu together.
Like, it's our Lu Bu.
What?
We all get to pursue him.
Whoa!
Oh my god!
I entertain him!
We entertain him!
Oh my god!
Lu Bu!
Take this.
Okay.
Win five duels without being injured?
Jesus Christ!
He has such high standards!
What the fuck?
Oh my!
Can I pay?
Let me see.
Okay.
Let's see if I can pay again.
Guys.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh.
It's you.
Oh my god.
I can.
Alright.
Let's go.
Nice.
We did it.
Alright.
Okay.
We did it.
We paid.
Do I think I can get another letter?
Let's see if there's another letter for me.
I spent all Guys, I spent all my money on Lu Bu.
Do you think?
Guys, I spent all my money on... There's a lesson in this, I think.
Okay.
I'm wailing for Lu Bu right now.
Guys.
Okay.
Wait.
I paid for it, so...
Okay.
He's still there.
Oh my god.
We're at level four, guys.
We're at level four.
Good lord.
Oh my god.
It's worth it, guys.
You don't understand.
You don't see the... You don't see the plan right now, but it's so worth it.
Guys, you don't understand.
It'll all be worth it in the end.
My lord.
You spent all our money on Lu Bu and now we're homeless.
Guys, I saved up for this occasion.
Chat.
Oh my god.
We're out in the balcony now.
Thank you.
It's called money.
It's called pay to win.
Oh, you think highly of me then?
I exist in this world.
Oh my god.
The music.
What?
Oh my god.
Oh shit.
I didn't think we'd get this far.
I suppose there's no escape.
Oh my god.
I'm moving so fast.
I'm moving way too fast.
Wow.
Oh fuck.
Okay.
Okay guys.
Wow.
I'm turning into Crash Bandicoot right now.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
That's not subtle.
That's not subtle at all guys.
That was not subtle.
He literally was like, I want you.
I need you as mine.
How am I supposed to interpret that?
How the fuck?
There is no bro relationship anymore.
Guys, do you think he likes me?
He likes us.
Guys, do you think he likes us?
Oh my god.
Okay.
I'm breathing.
What the shit?
What about Dad?
Well, you have a wife.
You have a wife.
But he has a wife.
Oh my god.
This is art.
Guys, we did this together.
Dude.
What do you mean fade him back?
Wait, what?
He doesn't even talk to his wife like this.
Oh my god.
We did it guys.
We're all in.
Guys, I think he forgot the sentence.
How do I interpret that?
How do I?
Guys, I don't think he's a roommate no more.
Guys.
I don't think.
Oh my god.
Alright, you know what?
That's it.
That's a good time.
That's a good ending.
Okay.
He wants more than just a wife.
That's a good ending.
I think it was super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Guys,
I told you.
Money fixes all problems.
Guys, maybe pay to win ain't so bad.
Chat.
Guys, we successfully pursued Lil Poo.
We did it.
We pursued him together.
Oh my god.
Well, I'm gonna call it here.
I think this was a good stopping point, everybody.
I'm gonna go rest my voice now.
I did not mean to yell that much today, but like some of these.
Oh my god.
I paid for a Lil Poo meet.
We paid for a Lil Poo meet and greet and I don't regret it.
I did not expect some of the.
I did not expect the store.
Some of the fucking routes to lead this way, but yeah.
Anyway guys, as always everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me, head to bed cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.